évidemment si on avait les fameuses
études là la caisse les pros mais pour
quelque part en septembre soit avalisée
tout ça sera un débat plus facile à
faire luc ferrandez anie samson bonsoir
mouvement à distance aux jeux commencent
avec vous en fait il ya deux cas les
spécialistes
les architectes et beaucoup de gens qui
ont dit ne faites pas ça en hauteur ça
votre difficulté laquelle répondent n'a
pas le choix j'en ai tout mais moi j'ai
hâte de voir les études en septembre
c'est un dossier qui très importante
depuis depuis toujours ou je pense que
c'est le plus gros projets
d'infrastructures qu'on va avoir ici à
montréal et à toutes les fois qu'on
parle de transport il ya toujours des
discussions on a eu la même chose avec
le métro la ligne bleue on en a parlé on
était presque arrivé une solution avec
l'époque godard dans le temps où j'étais
là et hop sont le changer d'idée en
cours de route on dirait qu'on ne parle
d'eux on a peur d'avoir peur qu'on en
parle ne pas choisir le bon projet ce
qu'il faut se rappeler c'est pourquoi on
a besoin d'un mode de transport qui va
jusque dans l'est de montréal la région
de l'ess représente en superficie la
même superficie que la ville de paris
on parle de 500 m2 population est là si
on a l'occasion rêvée de pouvoir enfin
rallier les deux solitudes l'ouest et
l'est est on est on est prêts on est
prêt et la photo qu'on nous ment on y
dit que le nouveau règne qui est prévue
aura une signature unique ça sera pas
celle qu'on a dans l'ouest de montréal
avec les pilotes de béton ce sera
quelque chose de signature unique on est
des gens ici les artistes sont capables
près vous vous faites confiance à
dissensions au processus puis vous dites
mais davantage que ça avance ce trailer
un jeunot luc ferrandez la méfiance
énorme autour de la caisse là dessus
vous en faites partie vous vous dites
pour une fois que ça avance un projet
non moi je suis méfiant parce que
d'abord c'est pas juste une structure de
béton c'est une structure de béton avec
par dessus une armature de poteaux qui
tiennent des cathéters donc sacré dans
la ville un schisme ça crée une
barrière losc passe et il faut regarder
rené lévesque en particulier entre le
pont jacques cartier et le centre-ville
c'est un cas un quartier énormément de
potentiel faut pas juste le voir comme
il est il est déjà pas mal mais il faut
le voir comme il peut devenir et ça peut
être un quartier fantastique d'ailleurs
il ya beaucoup de projets qui vont être
ici à la maison de radio-canada il va y
avoir un quartier résidentiel il ya
aussi le quartier sainte marie à côté du
beurre du pont donc il ya des nouveaux
quartiers qui s'en viennent on peut
réinventer si on est beaucoup de monde
qui utilisent leur et m on peut utiliser
l'espace au sol de façon différente on
te planter beaucoup d'arbres si l'udc
j'avais l'étude montgeard de la voir
aussi les études devrais-je et qui
arrive à la conclusion que c'est vrai
que c'est trop compliqué un tunnel sas
peur est ce que vous allez dire bon bain
allons-y quand même où jésus au grand
jamais pad aérien non elle est possible
mais moi je pense que c'est pas c'est
pas juste aérien ou souterrain est un
mythe le projet n'est pas juste un
projet de technologie kth ferme modèle
d'affaires et le modèle d'affaires
suppose que on va avoir une seule
infrastructure pareil partout qui va
desservir l'est de montréal mais après
qui va se rendre à repentigny qui va se
rendre au nord vers l'aval alors on veut
port ils veulent pas arrêter ce projet
là pour cette raison là mais s'il n'y
avait pas cette raison là si on
réfléchit au transport en commun à
montréal on dirait mer sans droit de ça
prend un tram ça prend un tramway aux
seuls initiés
oui mais le grand bain on réfléchit
depuis 40 ans puis fériés anil
exactement là où j'ai juste une paire
même que la beauté la sécu moi j'étais
extrêmement sceptique quand j'ai entendu
parler du rhin en 2010 et ils l'auront
centre de messages 2008 les travaux ont
commencé aujourd'hui et sont en train de
le tester sur la rive sud je me dis là
ont une chance incroyable d'avoir enfin
un service de transport pour les gens
qui les 500 milles qui demande à dans
l'est qui ont actuellement des voies
réservées qui ont des pistes cyclables
qui ont des autobus qui on parle de
montréal saint-laurent de pointe aux
trembles à venir à montréal 1h30 je
comprends que pour trois tronçons
peut-être dans le centre ville on peut
remettre en cause peut-être la façon
dont ça va être fait on ne peut pas
pénaliser les 500000 personnes qui de
l'autre côté on aussi une navette
fluviale qui les amène au centre ville
je sais pas ce que pour cinq cent mille
personnes ils sont en mesure et en droit
d'avoir les mêmes services pour se
rendre au centre ville que ceux qui
vivent au centre qu'il faut pas il faut
pas qu'on crucifix projet tout de suite
comme ça gagnants dont les études puis
regardons après comment pall est banni
il s'agit pas d'empêcher ces
personnes-là d'avoir un transport la rtm
et la stm tu leur donnes les mêmes
conditions opérationnelles que la caisse
ils vont produire un premier transport
de la même qualité de la même qualité il
faut faire confirmer sur une bleue on
leur fait confiance dans l'attentât non
et bien sûr parce que le gouvernement le
gouvernement a promis des fonds mais si
tu donnes à la stm à la rtm le mandat de
construire et avec la fameuse taxe qui
permet de récupérer 10 % des coûts de ce
projet en taxant les les aborder des
voix parce que c'est ça qui se fait avec
avec la crise c'est une manne les mêmes
conditions à la rtm gris donne à la
caisse ils voient devine avec un
magnifique proche la reportant sur la
campagne est ce qu'on est en train de
voir que madame plantes se positionne
dans les sceptiques très sceptique et
monsieur coderre dans les défenseurs
très défenseur ce que c'est c'est comme
ça que ça va se jouer mais j'ose espérer
que ça se fasse pas au niveau aa pour
avoir des votes ni d'un bar ni de
l'autre de façon électoraliste il faut
quand même se rappeler la raison pour
laquelle on peut le faire on a une
occasion qui devant nous ça veut pas
dire qu'on voit on va prendre n'importe
quel projet il ya des études qui s'en
viennent moi je moi j'y vais beaucoup
plus avec la confiance de regardant ce
qui se passe il ya un comité qui a été
mis en place avec des experts qui
actuellement sont en train de regarder
est ce qu'on est capable de faire un
projet d'avenir avec sa hotte en a rêvé
la ligne bleue autant l'on peut la
réaliser cette nouvelle ligne là le réel
qui a fait ses preuves avec ce qui a
déjà été livrés moi je pense aux
citoyens qui en ont besoin je pense à
cette moitié de la ville qui sont
desservies comme une seconde qui paient
des taxes qui ont droit aux mêmes
services à l'heure pas une heure et
demie dans arrivés à marjah cette fois
qu'on aboutisse et que bergeron avait
ses projets il y avait plein de projets
on peut on peut en parler milan mais il
faut que c'est luc ferrandez faut que ça
bouge vos beaux projets vous aviez pour
les grands parcs et tout ça oui mais là
c'est sûr qu'avec la caisse beaucoup ont
l'impression qu'ils aient un côté
bulldozers mais un bond aux yeux ça
avance oui oui ça c'est l'adage de la
caisse mais la vente à caen ça avance
quand tu regardes s'est construit après
petits groupes ce peut-être qu'on
n'aurait pas dû le faire comme ça et
c'est pas le cas pour la première phase
à part dans le vieux montréal là où
l'emploi passe à côté du globe pont
patrimonial qui avait là sur le canal
lachine mais en gros c'est pas ça parce
qu'il n'y a pas les mêmes enjeux quand
tu rentres dans la ville quand tu
rentres dans la ville ll faut que tu m
pour qu'il fasse attention moi j'ai
jamais vu j'ai jamais vue de ma carrière
une firme d'architectes se retirer d'un
projet parce qu'ils disent c'est
impossible qu'il soit beau on parle de
daou le stage on parle de la firme qui
offrait le quartier international de
montréal essayé pas pu à cette époque le
lieu tout le monde veut sa peau d'alice
d'un bâtiment qui est pas beau puis
quelques années pitance neuf radars oui
oui mais justement ce bâtiment là ce
bâtiment là qui recouvre l autoroute ils
sont des experts de l'intégration
urbaine ils ont un contrat juteux devant
les yeux et on leur dit qu'ils disent
non nous notre réputation est en jeu on
sort de là alors je suis d'accord avec
toi pour dire les experts doivent aussi
être écouté les experts en urbanisme
j'en ai pas entendu beaucoup qui disent
c'est une bonne idée est ce que je
propose c'est d'attendre aussi le comité
d'accompagnement sur l'intégration
urbaine nice-côte elle aussi va avoir
des choses attendons mais d'abord
prochaine étape c'est l'étude je fais 3
proche de 10 mais l'étude qui montre qui
a démontré à la caisse que c'est
impossible de fer souterrain on a de
l'avenir et on verra ensuite ani le
remercie beaucoup bonne fin de soirée
mercredi